welcome welcome welcome we are back with another
fantastic season of united shades of america with
kamau bell and ladies and gentlemen look who just
showed up on my screen it is not a muppet it is
the man himself but one day i think they will
have a muppet of you on sesame street it's gonna
happen don't worry we're working on it right
now um welcome uh how how many seasons is this
this is season seven the magical number seven
seasons yeah yeah you've got some great hall of
fame um showbiz hall of fame we're on our way um
so you have there's so much variety um in all the
seasons this one in particular because there are
some things in here that i was like oh i didn't
know that um and speaking of didn't know that
let's let's look at one of these clips this is
black folks in appalachia now i wasn't i
didn't know that which is ignorant on my part
um because what you usually see from
appalachia and the appalachian mountains
is uh you know white folks and it's usually you
know people who are destitute um and struggling
and this is a really interesting look so we're
going to look at that clip and then you're going
to talk to me about how it is you came up
with this and got there and what it was like
so i'm actually walking the appalachian trail
right now you are you are those mountains there
these are some of the oldest mountains in the
world when you see the swiss alps they're so
big that's because they're babies these are the
grandmothers crystal good is a sixth generation
west virginia native founder of black bog god
that's how you say it appalachia's first all
black newspaper she's gonna show me around and
introduce me to the people and places at the
core of black appalachia you know a lot of these
narratives that paint an appalachian stereotype
they forget that not all appalachia is
white people and folks like me and my family
don't necessarily get into that narrative and
that's why i'm excited to be i think the docent
of appalachia oh the dosage of appalachia
is that an official title i just made it up
the dosage of appalachia is that that's
new um what was it like um you know we
in the positions that we are in um have the
opportunity to go into places that a lot of people
aren't familiar with um and that we should be
going into more not less uh tell me what was
like being there and what you discovered well you
know it's funny a lot of the episodes this season
are sort of like a little bit of like follow-ups
of things we sort of maybe discovered along the
way of the last few of the first six seasons and
so i think it was in season two or three we did
an episode about uh coal miners in appalachia and
in that episode one of our producers gelding porus
walked past something called the lynch
colored school the lynch colored school and
she was like come out would be interested
to know what's going on in this building
and we met some black ex coal miners in appalachia
and so this was like there's more to find out
there than that one segment we did at the
show so this was about like going back in
and digging deep and actually really connecting
with a lot of the black communities in appalachia
and it's interesting it's it's it is definitely
not what you expect if you don't live there a
lot of mixed kids in appalachia so it's not
the communities are not separate and hating
on each other the way we might think in a place
like that they are they're pretty well mixed in
together because they're in the mountains and
there's not a lot of places to separate i think
all right i and that one i'm just i can't wait to
see the whole episode um you always bring to light
so many things that we um just aren't familiar
with on a grand scale in this country um now your
next one is we're going we are swinging we're
just going like this like whiplash um it's just
whiplash and i love it um athletes and the cost
of winning we're going to look at this clip um
athletics has always brought us together in some
way shape or form especially during the olympics
where people feel great pride um i want everyone
to see this clip first and then we will talk
about it on the back end as quiet as it's kept
gymnastics is as hard and pressure-filled a sport
as they come football's tough but they wear pads
the only pads you see here whoa are the calluses
oh my gosh oh my hamstrings all right cartwheel
oh this is you better get weight in front of me
so i don't know if you guys know this but
uh competitive gymnastics is really hard
just just a little bit just a tad coaches sarah
mullow brianna mcneill and mike hahn have been
teaching at reading gymnastics for a combined
38 years while this may be the 7 to 10 year olds
class this ain't child's play oh my goodness if
you're a competitive what's your daily schedule
like they go to school and then coming to this
club practice what time are you leaving here for
a nighttime practice you were out here at nine
most days so then you go home and do homework
mm-hmm wow i mean it is a lot and is it
too much well the thing gymnasts are so
disciplined if you can handle gymnastics you can
handle mostly anything i feel how did i do today
let's talk about that will i
ever be as good as you all no no
how excellent no i don't think it's
fair i appreciate your honesty i apprec
and why won't i ever be as good
as you all i need to shrink
and so what do you want to do in gymnastics how
far do you want to go i want to go to the olympics
okay i also want to go to the
olympics olympics olympics
um probably a teacher a teacher
who goes to the olympics
um but then it turns to something that we all
right struggle with so you start with this very
light fun difficult um scenario with these
kids tell me where this goes you know this
one this segment was was pretty personal for me
because i had two i have three daughters but two
daughters who started out doing gymnastics
the way all lots of little kids little girls
especially started doing gymnastics and
then there was a point in which my older
daughter was sort of like plucked into the
oh you might be good at this side of things
and and what i saw was how it became a lot
less fun for her and she eventually dropped out
and at the same time that was happening i did
the the all the stories broke of dr larry nassar
and all the abuse and sexual abuse of young girls
and and women that he had done while working with
team usa gymnastics and so as a parent me and my
wife were like i'm not mad at you for dropping out
of gymnastics because i don't know that this
is a safe place for you so i talked to the
all three of the people you saw me talking to
there you know it's an awkward time to bring that
up in the gym but i brought it up with while after
the little girls had left about like how do you
deal with being a gymnastics coach right now and
then you're also talking about like simone biles
getting the twisties and how dangerous gymnastics
is so we we like to see the glory but we don't
like to know what's going on behind the scenes and
so we talked about that because because you know
and also the fact is that you know some of these
girls who say they want to go to the olympics
their coaches know a lot of them are not going to
the olympics already but they're not telling them
that necessarily so it is a it really to me it
was really important to do that and it was really
you know it's easy to sort of do the cute kid
part but i wouldn't have been doing what i do
as a as a human and as a as a parent who had kids
in gymnastics without bringing up the other stuff
you don't know this but i will my best friend
uh was a collegiate gymnast um who was in that
upper rung who was a potential you know heading
on to the the world and that sort of thing and she
started at five and the stories she tells me about
mental mental health about how she used to go to
bed completely covered in like 10 000 blankets to
try to lose weight they were weighed every single
time there's all these things people have no idea
how hard it is on these kids and she was committed
to it and she wanted to do it but you know there
were issues in her gym too and so i think um this
is a really important uh topic uh for any athlete
or for anyone that's a part of a team right i mean
the mental health aspect of anything um we are
finally starting to talk about thank goodness
definitely and i think that like you
know i think the other thing about
but what we call women's gymnastics often
involves teenagers you know so i think the
other thing is that these are these are
young women or kids who are sort of being
like encouraged to make decisions that will
affect the rest of their lives at a time when
shouldn't you just be having fun you know should
are you prepared to to to go to this class go to
coaching and then go do homework at nine o'clock
at night as an 11 year old you know what i mean so
to me there's a we we asked all those questions
and it's it's important right the pressure
it's real the pressure is really real when you
get into those sort of very upper echelons of
competing um this this next one is near and
dear to my heart um as someone who's lived in
in california for a very long time uh the title is
california is burning that is all you need to know
about what's coming up next let's watch that
clip a couple years ago the campfire burned
just quarter mile from here and so they've been
kind of living with this extreme fear of fire
and so we got this effort started locally to
make it easier for landowners to burn their
own land the objectives to not kill the big trees
but we do want to kill little baby trees we want
to kill brush the more the communities
that live in these kinds of environments
can use fire the better off they're going to be if
you each grab a torch um we'll get moving on this
my eight-year-old dreams come true this is part
of a larger conservation project that don and zeke
are involved in training people in the practice
of prescribed fire we got lots of different fuel
types out here right we got oak leaves we got pine
needles pine needles burn better and i'm learning
along with other members of the community they
want to help protect our state by safely using
good fire in a controlled setting the key
word is controlled good day to light a fire
there you go that's good let's
go we're just burning up the easy
dry grass and we're going to just work
our way down slope with our ignitions
small spot fires are slowly lit down
the hill supervised by zeke and don
everyone has a radio and a weather spotter
checks for any sudden changes in the wind
and cal fire officers are standing by can you
tell i'm trying to say don't try this at home
um you with a blow torch i listen
maybe not a like good out there
we got a hat that fit me i was i looked like
i was ready for for action and you know you
don't want you would you want to hear the hair
no no no here's uh lloyd's of london ensured
but yeah as you see the episode it really
that we set a lot of that part of the land
on fire and i think the the big takeaway
from that episode is that california
and large parts of the world have to learn how to
live with fire you can't stop these fires nature
uses fire as a way to sort of keep
nature at bay it's like nature's haircut
but the problem is that because we've encroached
on nature so much we haven't allowed nature to
do it in a way that's healthy and so this is
about encouraging nature in a positive way
you know there is such a serious serious side to
this um i love you always come at it with such
such good humor but you always get to the the
hard part and the hard parts are we have seen
what has happened um it was incredible to me how
quickly the the pine needles caught i mean it was
you didn't have to do anything he's just like
oh no that's gay it's on fire um but for anyone
who lives in the west in particular um across
the west these fires are getting hotter they're
burning faster they are sometimes just impossible
to control you talk to any firefighter who goes
out and deals with wildfires um and we're in a
real situation here what did what did you learn
about me you're in california what did you learn
about how bad things could get or are getting
well it's it's it's brought me a
whole new level of respect for what we
make fun of the weather man or the weather weather
woman as far as like weather really determines a
lot of this so california wildfires can make
the air bad in montana so the idea being that
like even if you think this is just a california
issue that air that the toxic air from the fires
can spread all over the country i think he got
out to new york at one point but so i think the
idea being that like we we sort of think we think
fire understands the state's lines and borders but
fire does not understand that and then i talked to
some firefighters who talked about how much longer
the fire season has gotten in california as you
know we have winter spring summer fall and fire
season and fire season used to be a part of the
summer into the early fall and now it is most is
most if not all of the summer into into sometimes
the winter because we are in a drought so you know
firefighters are being exhausted out here they
can't they can't find enough firefighters and then
this is where the united states double bell park
comes in we actually train the state of california
trains inmates to be firefighters when they're in
prison but then when they get out of prison people
don't want to hire those firefighters because they
were in prison so there's a fire fire shortage but
we also don't want to hire the people we trained
to be firefighters uh while they were in prison
you know what you get to all the things you just
always get the whole thing um this next one i'm a
bit jealous uh because you it's the clip is called
hawaii for hawaiians i'm gonna leave it there and
keep my jealousy at bay as we watch this clip so
i sat down with three native hawaiians on waikiki
beach a famous surf spot and the epicenter of
hawaii's tourism industry jody clark cliff capono
and khaleese kelly opa'a are world-class surfers
who are continuing the native tradition of this
sport surfing is something that's passed along
i think you can see it throughout the islands we
bring our children to the beach and we put
them on surfboards seems like it'd be a hard
place to surf if you're a local i look out
there it's it looks like the dmv in the ocean
when you grow up here yeah you learn how to
navigate your way totally throughout all these
people so is this beach always like this always
never seen an empty waikiki kuhio beach like
when kovid happened hawaiian families that don't
normally come down here because it's so crowded
they got to enjoy waikiki clean beautiful beach
i it was amazing within a month the ocean life
restored itself fish that i've never seen in my
life that come in schools i think we cherish that
moment so so much because that is what hawaii
could have been there's nobody here except for
hawaiian local families yeah it's like little
rules too that you have when we see another
family at the beach we don't sit in front of them
because it's like you're connecting with the ocean
with your family but here they'll just see you and
oh there's a better spot right in front of you and
they'll just sit right in front isn't that the
whole like you know the whole problem of sort of
tourism as it's currently constructed is that
it's about me i'm going to hawaii with my family
and we want to have our hawaii experience
i'm only here for six nights and seven days
wow now you know you gonna get some
response from from the tourists like us
i got some response from the tourists
who watched the edits of this show
tell me what sparked this because it is a very
interesting concept to make people think outside
of themselves you know we so we did a hawaii
episode uh a couple seasons ago and it was really
about sort of really establishing the fact that
hawaii was stolen by the united states of america
that hawaii never said we would like to become a
state and so it was really just about establishing
the fact that when we think of native land in
this country we need to be thinking of hawaii
as native land that really has a lot of its native
still on it we think about the united states
genocide of native americans you don't see native
americans that often unless you are in community
with them but on hawaii the natives are very much
still there and so the idea we did that episode
and this became an episode that in a large part
was informed by the pandemic because at a time
when many continental americans who had means and
money couldn't travel outside of the country they
looked at hawaii as being outside the country
and then many people as they were remote working
were like i can remote work from hawaii but again
they come in with a tourist mentality oh there's
we talked about in this episode about the idea of
people on instagram posting undiscovered beaches
in hawaii as if hawaii didn't know that those
beaches were there you know so the idea being
that we look at is like as like a foreign land
that has been undiscovered and when you say that
you're ignoring the fact that people have lived
there as they would say since time immemorial
that's fair enough and it is an interesting
way to flip the the sort of tourism industry
on its head because it also you know
has its impacts um economically which
you know the governments of course and some
of the people they're like but there is a very
different side to it um i'm absolutely i
would say and i would say that too is that
we talk we actually talk to people who
work in the hotels there some of the uh
staff that works in hotels and they're finding
right now that post pandemic the hotel industry
has really come back the hotels are like 89
capacity but the people who run the hotels
have learned that those of us who are tourists
have learned to expect less because of cobit
so then they are then laying off a lot of their
staff because they can tell us we're not going
to clean your room every day because of cobin and
we're like oh thank you for not cleaning my room
every day what that means is that a whole bunch of
staff gets laid off and these a lot of people are
in unions so then they're just sort of waiting
for when they can come back to work and so it's
you know even those people who work in the tourist
industry who rely on the tourist industry for
their income know that there's a problem with it
for every action there is an equal and opposite
reaction didn't we learn that in school did
you learn i learned that on sesame street
um we are we are okay can i just admit something
i really hate this word but i'm gonna oh i don't
know what it is can i can i get it's like
a game shook and i guess yeah go ahead woke
ding ding ding ding ding ding that word i don't
know why it grates on my nerves but it does
um i think it's because it's partly been
co-opted anyway there's just you know um
yeah yes your next clip is called and i'm saying
it only for you come out the woke war here it is
crt i think stands for causes racial tension i've
seen it at boards i've seen it at board meetings
and it's very divisive it's not unifying and it
turns american values upside down crt is using
race because it's immutable it's immutable what do
you mean it's immutable you can't change your race
i mean you're stuck you are what you
are as you said it's an academic turn
isn't it a way they're observing racing how it
functions through the law in american society i
don't know and to give an example of something
that crt might cover is for instance say
redlining in the 70s and they would explain okay
the reason we have these huge disparities between
black and white homeownership is because there
was redlining which by the way literally was a
red line that was drawn around there
are maps with red lines around black
do you know that there is still i can't help it
i can't there is one of our reporters nick what
this wonderful story in beverly hills there
are still clauses about not letting black
folks and jewish folks live in beverly hills
it's still in the paperwork and they said well
we're not going to change it because this costs
too much money bubble but it is still there
so yeah yeah yeah well yeah this
is a big one and a divisiveness
lord please do you have to keep saying the
word we wanted to call this one world war
woke but we couldn't get away with it oh my god
that i literally was thinking that that would
be the perfect title um so the bottom line is
this one is going to set people on fire right i
mean literally with the arguments uh what did you
tackle what did what drew you to this other than
the complete obviousness of we're fighting over
it like cats and dogs i mean it was one of those
things that you know this in the news the stories
are sort of out there and those of us who were
inside this industry sort of like sometimes
we're like are we really talking about this
and you sort of wait for it to go away and it
doesn't go away and so it sort of felt like an
assignment it didn't really feel like a thing that
i was like ooh let's do this but then it's like
if we're gonna do this how do we do this in a way
that feels that feels like we're we're helping or
we're at additive and not just exploitative and
so we went into the whole school idea the idea
of like because the scary thing about the woke
war as we call it is that right now there are
schools that are not going to teach an accurate
history of the united states of america because
they have decided that crt is in the schools
and the schools are getting too woke and that
means the next generation of kids is not going to
have access to the same type of facts that me and
you grew up with and when when we see where the
country's at is now that is scary that is scary to
think that we are going to literally whitewash
this through this country and it will affect
how this country goes forward and right now it's
basically a jump ball if this american democracy
lasts much longer so for me this is like we have
to go through the school through the idea of the
school districts and then we talked to teenagers
in high school about the fact because this woke
thing we think about is race but it also gets
into the lgbtq plus community and kids who are
in school who are now as we talk about a little
bit don't say gay bill in florida the so-called
don't say april uh what i call it the don't say
gay bill we talk about that is the idea is that
you're actually erasing the lives of the kids who
are in school right now and what and what kind of
schools should be doing that who wants to go to
a school that is actually a race in your life
and i have to say you always you know talk to
many of the facets and the sides if you will um of
these issues and and get out in a very humane way
and i and i do appreciate that and i think you're
the people who watch um really appreciate that um
you said that this was sort of the assignment was
trying to get to where we are did you understand
the assignment that's all i need to know
right now the way i wanted to understand
the assignment the way i was raised to
understand the assignment so yeah i think
well you want to show the assignment
no it's this one takes place in arizona so
no better place to do this in arizona maybe
florida but we did it in arizona yeah i mean
it's listen it's all across the country uh
virginia arizona florida you you name the
place um san francisco i mean they they're
folks it's a really really really interesting um
i mean you know elite private schools in new york
i mean it's like it is not a left right issue you
know it's touched a lot of people and a lot of
people who don't have kids in school too i noticed
we'll show up at some of these board meetings we
have one of the people in that thing not in there
do not have kingpin schools and they're in there
all right our next one another one close to my
heart um asian americans in the spotlight um
you this is this is sort of a personal journey
um for you and for those that are that are
represented in this piece let's watch
the clip let's talk about your journey
in here i i've read your bio it's a
bio that any parent would be proud of
bing chen lives in the future when
he was a big wig at youtube he saw
influencer culture coming and helped to make
sure that influencers got paid for it he's
an entrepreneur who sees a future where asian
americans get all the representation they want
and more the best analog i had when i was a kid
was like walt disney makes dreams come true how do
you make that real like how do you make anyone's
dream come true at a really practical level
it starts with gold house his non-profit
collective of asian american leaders that
basically make sure that when asian media comes
out people are looking for it we are looking at
the asian diaspora where the majority of the world
4.5 billion were the fastest growing population in
this country and yet we are the most objectified
immediate so there's just this clear disparity
and so i think the imperative for an institution
like gold house that we collectively created it
just goes to the age-old adage of you can either
take a house or you can build your own house
one of its first big successes was getting
the word out about crazy rich asians
and the question was how do we ensure that this is
successful because the film right now is going to
underperform and so we said all right we're going
to get everyone together in a way they never have
for years black folks have encouraged people
to support black movies by buying out theaters
because in hollywood if a movie has a big opening
weekend then more movies like that get made
that means more representation gold house
borrowed that idea for the opening weekend
of crazy rich asians and it worked to
the tune of almost 240 million dollars
this movie is making history the
summer blockbuster crazy rich asians
seeing what goldhouse did for crazy rich asians
really it's showing the power that the community
has i had some concerns like is this the movie
that we want to do it's not michael yeah exactly
exactly crazy rich asians how i justified it was
it was still a love story and you never saw asians
in rom-coms so many of us who've been in the
business for a long time have sort of felt like
we've been the only one climbing up this
ladder and it's a very lonely ladder and so
to know that there are organizations now taking
it upon themselves right to promote and to build
infrastructure well the fact that we're having
this conversation right now for television
you know means we're moving
in the right direction yeah
this is i i love i love all your guests nice to
see lisa i know that was the the first lisa ling
uh you know the first time you listening if i had
a question or so when i when i released when we
were conceiving this show i was like we have to
get lisa me and lisa i have gotten a lot closer
since the pandemic we've just you know connected
a lot and so i really value her as a friend and
really in some sense want to pay tribute to her
as someone who has been doing this work for a
long time and really feel like i don't i don't
know that lisa's gotten all of her flowers and
so i wanted to be make sure that i was there to
help throw some of those flowers at her feet and
hand them to her because i think she she is a
revolutionary force for good in this industry
yeah she's she embodies so many good
things um when you look at this you know
something struck me in that clip and
it it was you know i love the movie
was it me me eating with my mouth open
was that what struck you with that clip
listen listen i'm sure your mother will have
something to say i have met your mother i'm sure
she will have something to say like come out it's
hard to eat and talk i know always a bad idea but
we do it it's life right um especially when
it gets caught on camera um but what what what
struck me is you know we look at some of these
movies and now that they're successful right
everyone's like oh god i've got to make more i
got to do but what it takes to do that because um
the studios or whomever are behind some of these
films think it's too niche is so upsetting it's
it is as if human beings cannot you know watch
someone who doesn't look exactly like them and not
feel the humanity of that other person if a movie
is good i don't care who's in it it's good right
yeah and it's also it everything doesn't have to
be for everybody i think we understand that with
whiteness that there's like you know i'm
sure kevin costner is making another golf
movie right now you know like i'm sure he's he
keeps you know there's they keep making westerns
kevin coster's obviously making another western
right now we have to unders everything is not for
everybody and so like for example with right now
my daughters are watching ms marvel on disney plus
they are not south asian they do not live in new
new jersey like she does but she is a brown girl
who is doing a great magical superhero things
that they relate to and when you look at the the
who made miss marvel it is clearly intentional
that it was made by people from this culture
and whereas like if that miss marvel had been
made 10 years ago it probably would be made by
white men and they would have cast just the
brown people on on camera so the important
part is as we have slowly started to learn
representation is also important behind the
camera which is why helen was there helen cho was
there who's directed episode of the united shades
and also is the show order for lisa ling show
takeout because she's somebody when i met her
she had never directed before and she came to me
and was like i want to direct an episode of the
united shade she'd worked with parts unknown with
tony for years and never gotten to direct she's
like is that okay and i was like of course
it's okay why would i why would i stop you
and so that's also the the important part of
this episode is about representation on camera
behind the scenes in politics we talked
to a politician in podcasting for we have
little uh chinese american kids podcasting
representation everywhere not just on camera
yeah it's a it's really um an important um part
of our society and people don't realize how
impactful uh movies have been in many of
our lives and i think you could say that
still for the population i you know i can
remember so many films that like drew me in
uh books as well uh written by different people
and i you know i mean i'm i'll watch dumb and
dumber and laugh my behind off um but i also want
to see malcolm x right i also want to see those
films um and so it i i just i think this episode
is really going to speak to a lot of people
um all right i mean you got so many episodes
here i mean did you sleep at all when you
i mean no i mean we're let's remember there's
still a pandemic happening so there was all
that stress too we were just able to be inside a
little bit more this season so this was this was a
this was one of the hardest seasons we've
ever filmed at this show because we were
still dealing with the pandemic and also we're
dealing with the fraying of american democracy
happening all around us and feeling like these
episodes have to address that have to be clear
which is still happening now considering what
is is going on with the gm6 committee and all
the things that we've been seeing
i mean we're in a very serious time
how does kamal bell keep all that humor just
put it on a plate for all of us to to eat off of
every single day i mean i wouldn't know how
to do this if i wasn't laughing sometimes
so like uh and if i wasn't allowed to be myself
i think even in that scene in the scene we showed
from the woke episode when the guy says crt means
causing racial tension you can see my face like
i don't know like that's me sort of like
alleviating the tension so i don't just
start screaming and crying you know now there
are times actually before that scene because
we've been shooting all this woke stuff and i've
been talking about these people who i didn't
agree with i just laid on the ground before that
scene just to be like black jesus helped me get
through this next city so there are times where
i have to take a mental health break uh it's why
it's important that the crew this is the first
season show we've had an all-black camera crew
it really helps to have a crew that i can look
at who who afterwards when the scene ends they
can be like brother you did it i saw it i felt it
they know what i'm going through so for me it's
like it's really about making sure i'm surrounded
with people who get it and also without the humor
i don't know i wouldn't be of any use to this job
i don't think because i'm i'm not a journalist as
you point out all the time i do not point that out
that's that's all on you because you do represent
the different sides of the argument which is
journalistically sound i would like to say
um and you do it with humor but you
come at it from a certain perspective
um and you're clear about that this isn't
you know you hiding anything this is you like
letting it all hang out there and like you said
if you weren't laughing you might be crying so
uh laughter i i would i would vote for
laughter every single time kamau bell i
cannot wait to see season seven of united shades
of america with kamal bell we got to make sure
that name is always on there yeah yeah it's
you i fought to get my name in the title so
listen i know why and i love it it's great um
thank you so much uh we i will be seeing you on tv
maybe one day i'll actually see you
in person because right now you've
just been a hologram to me you know what i mean
exactly one day one day thanks kamal thank you
you